his paintings caught the eye of the
queen so much so she personally
appointed Freddie pask his job to
capture on canvas her Jubilee it was
very surreal it was a very surreal
moment and I remember reading the email
and it was just incredible to know that
the queen of senior work and that she
had
approved this this role to kind of
create a collection Freddie painted
every part of the parade from early
rehearsals in the park to the big day
itself so much pressure I I couldn't
tell you how much pressure I was under
as I was slowly sketching Out rough
ideas and I knew she was
incredibly knowledgeable about her
horses and not just her horses but the
horses of the household Cavalry and all
these praise the king's troop and so I
knew I had to get that right
the queen never saw the painting she'd
commissioned created to celebrate her
Reign now a reflection of her Legacy and
as her last artist in Residence Freddie
was asked to paint after the Queen's
death from the funeral procession to the
lying in state a lot of the painting is
just the Dark Shadows of Westminster and
then the the light casting Through the
Windows and there's something just
really lovely about it this Aura this
kind of feeling of reverence as everyone
was going past in a year of celebrations
and commemorations Freddie Park painted
it all I think it's one of the saddest
things that has stayed with me was that
she set the wheels animation for this
amazing project and and lit the fire and
she never got to see the end result but
I hope I've done her justice uni she'll
know Freddie never found out why the
queen chose him but there was something
here that sparked Her Imagination Laura
bundock Sky News